good morning belief nation today's
message is get out of Loserville over to
you Quentin Tarantino I got a uh yeah I
started working at this video store was
pretty much what you're talking about
around that time and and it was great at
first because I'd always hated day jobs
and stuff and so I got a day job and it
ended up being pretty good but the
middlee I was there for five years at a
certain point it was our narcotic
alright I didn't have to keep pursuing
my dreams because you know it's not what
I want to do but it's sort of kind of
close and if I didn't have an artist
soul burning in me I could have made
myself happy with that I could if i if i
didn't have an artist soul burning to
get out I could have you know walked
backwards a couple steps and just done
that and would have been a fulfilling to
anybody else it would have been a
fulfilling life it wouldn't been for me
because I wouldn't know and I were to
have something to say that I didn't get
a chance to say but it did put me to
sleep for a while and and I've always
just thought I mean what really got it
got everything kind of truly going from
you could point out a lot of different
things but the bottom line is the fact
that I realized that the even the group
of people I hung around with they were
all great great great fellows and great
gals but you know I was easy for me to
think that I was doing a lot because I
was doing more to try to move myself
forward than they were but you know
that's not yeah yeah ok I'm a big fish
in a puddle so what all right they're
not doing anything all right so yeah I'm
doing more than them but um I realized
that actually I need to get my ass out
to Hollywood and meet other people who
are you know like they were in my
category or or working a little higher
and and I should be the weakest link in
my chain that I have and that'll make me
be stronger or make me run faster I mean
like an analogy I've always used is
alright if you run
the hundred yard dash with a people that
can't run as fast as yeah you'll win
hands down you know that but if you run
with people much faster than you all
right yeah you might come in last every
single time but your time will be better
because they're making you run all the
faster they're making they're making you
dig down just a little bit more it
doesn't matter that you and your time is
faster and that's what I knew I had to
do I had to get out of Loserville and
throw myself into a place where like
this is what furs do for a living I love
this message and it's one that I
resonate deeply with because it comes
back to the environment and you hear
this on my channel over and over and
over again the environment that you
surround yourself with matters and it
holds you where you are and to his point
you know it's great that you're the best
in your circle but that doesn't mean a
lot that doesn't mean you're gonna go
off and change the world and have a huge
impact and it's something that I
struggle with because a lot of the
people in my life a lot of the the
friends that I have they think I'm doing
great there's like Evan man you're doing
so well you're on fire you know and I
think like I need something to push me
right like I'm happy with what I've done
but I need to do more right and who's
pushing me to do more and I think that's
something that's really missing in my
environment and and I didn't solve it by
going to Hollywood I've solved it by
creating the top ten series and creating
this and spresso series and surrounding
myself with huge entrepreneurs and game
changers and revolutionaries and people
with amazing ideas and visionaries and I
see what they're doing and I consider
them to be part of my environment and
every single day I'm watching videos
from people who inspire me to do more
where I look at what they're doing and
then I look at what I'm doing and I
realize man I am just a tiny fish right
I have done nothing compared to most of
the people that I look up to and I try
to surround myself with and so yeah if I
was in a race with them I would come and
last but my time would be better and so
I think it's such a great analogy in
such a great thought process to look at
the people around you and are they
pushing to be better you know are they
challenging you are they saying that you
know it's great what you've done so far
but you could be more do you have people
who believe in you
more than you believe in yourself and
push you to be that best version of
yourself and if you don't you need to
find it you know you need to first
eliminate the little man from your life
eliminate the haters and the negative
people but then you still are left with
a bunch of people who support you who
love you who think you're great but they
don't push you to be better and without
people pushing you to be better then you
get stuck in an okay environment you get
stuck being the big fish in a puddle
right and so having people around you or
create an environment that pushes you to
do more by reading books by watching
videos by you know reading magazines and
by you know surround yourself with ideas
from people who are doing amazing things
amazing things changing that environment
maybe it means leaving your city maybe
it means going to a place where there is
more action but not being satisfied with
the environment that you currently have
around you and ask yourself is this
environment great right in my constant
getting better my being pushed by the
people around me because you can't do
great things and let's just surround it
by greatness so the question today today
is are you stuck in Loserville kind of
heart searching answer on that one leave
in the comments below really curious to
find out thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press